we have a voicemail today that kind of
bummed me out it really kind of made me
depressed
the phone numbers to 192 david p you can
call it anytime my question to the
audience is does this voicemail make you
as depressed as it made me take a listen
go David this is all kind of meaningless
honestly if you don't love what you're
doing don't be doing it was that it no
nothing really the money doesn't matter
like nothing really matters nothing
really matters just don't be doing
something you hate okay is that it yeah
okay is that it that is it I don't know
what this was in response to like I
don't know I don't remember saying
anything recently about the meaning of
life or anything of the sort like do you
know what this might be in response to
could be career advice for you like if
you're just so depressed day-to-day
covering all these stories oh no what
Trump and Republicans are doing yeah
maybe it's time for you to look
elsewhere
this type of nihilism and fatalism
really bums me out and like listen I get
it eventually the Sun is going to swell
and engulf the earth and unless humans
have moved on to some other solar system
we're all going to die and individually
we all have these minut lifespans and
were nothing more than motes of dust in
a endless universe I get all that stuff
but this type of nihilism and and
fatalism is is still really depressing
to me and I don't know if that's me
being naive and just feeling like I want
to bury my head in the sand and not
think about it but I found myself really
bummed out by this voicemail yeah
and I hope this caller is seeking help
if he needs it for himself yeah I don't
want to take this advice that's for if
this is if the voicemail is not so
directly related to something I said but
this is someone who is experiencing
depression then absolutely there are
countless resources available to you and
I would encourage you to get in touch
but if it's just general existential
nihilistic
anxiety mm-hmm then well it certainly
has served to put a damper on today's
show that's for sure
on today's bonus show Donald Trump is
tweeting the support of the Harley
Davidson boycott Yemen is bearing
children killed by an airstrike which
Riyadh insists was a legitimate raid and
we will also talk about the problem of
civics education in the United States
get access to the bonus show instantly
by becoming a member at WWJ impact
mancom or by becoming a patron at
patreon.com slash david pakman show